La volta al món a peu, dia 281. Us ho prometo que no he mirat.
Anem a comprovar la temperatura mínima d'aquesta nit, segons el rellotge.
Apostes, jo dic menys dos. A veure.
Ara menys tres, i la mínima de menys cinc.
Uau!
Uau, uau, uau, no m'esperava. Doncs no he tingut tant de fred, eh?
Ara es va escalfant el rellotge perquè el vaig tocar amb la mà, saps?
Bueno, me'n quedo una estona més al sac.
Doncs sí, menys cinc graus, la temperatura més freda de la meva vida,
però temperatura exterior, és a dir, jo he estat superbé.
Inclús m'he hagut d'obrir la jaqueta en algun moment dintre el sac perquè feia calor.
Bona!
Bona, bona, bona compra.
Sí, sí, sí, sí.
Però, jo què sé, potser és la nit més freda de la volta amb una peu.
Ara estic enviant missatges amb el Garmin, perquè aquí no hi ha cobertura.
Llavors estic informant la meva família que estic bé i que he sobreviscut la nit.
De fet, els missatges són predefinits. Només puc enviar en castellà.
Estic bé, estic començant la meva ruta o estic acabant la meva ruta, però bé, suficient.
Bé, mentida, podria enviar missatges personalitzats, però llavors tenen un cost adicional i no cal.
Bé, ara estava aquí i de cop i volta, a dintre, sento fora com un cavall.
Toc, toc, toc, ostres!
Surto i no hi havia cap cavall.
Hi havia pedres que caien de la tartera aquesta que hi ha aquí darrere.
Miro dalt i hi havia unes cabres, tu, ara ja no hi són, però quina imatge, tu, les cabres allà, a dalt de tot, eh?
Molt guapo.
Bé, són les 7.39.
És relativament tard, però estic satisfet perquè, clar, no podia sortir a les sis i pico perquè feia massa fred.
Encara és prou d'hora.
Avui, entre altres coses, he de creuar un riu.
Sense pont.
Fixa't, ja ha sortit el sol i mània curta.
Surrealista.
Bé, cal trobar el camí de tornada al camí.
Vaig a la redundància.
Et queda per aquí.
Et queda per aquí aquesta jungla.
I ara he de saltar aquestes pedres.
Sempre un moment delicat.
I opa, ja està.
I el camí és aquí.
Som-hi.
Bé, doncs m'he trobat aquestes vaques al camí.
Clar, quan m'han vist, que m'he apropat, han començat a fugir a la seva velocitat.
I clar, com només hi ha un camí, doncs les tinc aquí al davant.
I segueixen caminant mentre jo segueixi caminant.
Si hi hagués una obertura, es podrien apartar o em podria apartar jo.
Però no, res.
Home, com a mínim, no em perdré, no?
Això sí, fa una pudor anar darrere d'elles.
Buah.
Fins demà.
Estones.
S'avança ràpid perquè és així.
I a estones, com ara, comença dues coses.
les plantes que punxen.
Totes aquestes plantes punxen.
I dos, buscar el camí.
Perquè no és tan evident, eh?
De fet, hi ha moments en els quals
la traça original ja no existeix
i s'ha de fer una alternativa
que ja està marcada o per les vaques o per les persones.
He hagut de fer algun creuament d'aquests pitjors que aquest, eh?
Perquè ha sigut sobre troncs.
No l'he gravat perquè era bastant delicat.
Jo crec que he de tenir punxes per a tot arreu, tu.
Però bueno.
Mira.
M'agrada. Estic fatigat avui, he de dir, eh?
Clar, és que porto uns dies.
Heavy metal.
I avui...
Avui déu-n'hi-do.
Avui no són tants quilòmetres.
Són 40 quilòmetres
fins a Buyu... Ostres.
Buyu no sé què, després us ho dic.
Que és el poble més fred de la Unió Soviètica.
O sigui, quan un pensa a un...
al lloc més fred del món,
bueno, hi ha llocs a Sibèria
on s'han registrat temperatures molt loques, no?
Però jo he llegit por ahí.
Que el poble aquest on vaig
es va registrar 63 graus negatius.
I no sé, és la temperatura més baixa registrada a la Unió Soviètica
perquè Tadjikistan era part de la Unió Soviètica.
No puc caminar i parlar a la vegada.
Descent davant de les punxes, mira.
Una pujada tartarosa aquí.
Algú ha fet un camí, eh?
Perquè mira, això és una esllavissada.
Suposo que molt antiga.
I algú s'ha dedicat a fer el camí, eh? Molt bé.
Per això vaig pagar-hi 12 euros per l'entrada.
Vinga, ara Rierol amb punxes.
Vaques, per què no veniu a menjar això?
What? Mira, mira, mira.
Ai, és que m'estic punxant jo.
Com passo per allà després? Per aquí?
Oh!
Ah! Ah!
Oh! Vale, vale.
Vinga, ara últimes punxes.
És que ja és això la selva, eh?
La selva i el desert, eh? Després.
No puc ni... ni avançar.
No puc sortir d'aquí.
Ostres! He trencat la branca.
He de passar per sota, o què?
Oh!
Ai!
Vale, vale.
He parat allò, placa solar.
La tinc, la tinc. Vinga, som-hi.
Mira, mira.
Mira quin paisatge he d'anar ara.
Sembla la superfície de Mart.
Si trobes l'aigua.
És que no hi ha absolutament res.
Ni matois.
No hi ha absolutament res.
Vale.
Després d'aquest turonet,
hi ha el creuament de rius sense pont.
A veure com és el riu.
Si és molt caudalós o no.
A veure...
Ostres!
Doncs deu-n'hi-do dret, eh?
Ostres, tu!
Deu-n'hi-do dret lo fort que baixa, eh?
Bueno, a veure de veure per on es creua.
Suposo que per...
que allà al mapa m'indicarà la zona
menys... menys lluny, no?
Potser allà, que és més ample.
I estarà menys fons.
Doncs el mapa diu que per aquí,
per començar,
he de tornar a passar
mur de vegetació.
Ostres, tu!
Uah!
Brutal!
Hòstia, tu!
Vale.
Ho tinc tot.
El primer tram, facilet, per aquí.
Pum, pum, pum.
I ara...
Ara ve lo xungo.
Vale.
O per allà.
No ho sé, eh? Jo crec que per aquí.
Si per allà ho veig massa...
massa caudalós.
Aquesta part, molt fàcil,
ho veiem massa caudalós. En canvi aquí,
doncs bueno,
és prou...
I aquí què?
Aquí fàcil, no?
Bueno, un moment, eh?
D'acord, gravaré vertical perquè
puc ficar el gran angular
i crec que se'm veurà millor
tot. Tant el cos
com la cara, es veurà tot.
He decidit creuar descalç.
Bueno, amb mitjons.
Les sabatilles penjades a la motxilla.
Potser és un error, perquè em puc fer mal
els peus, però jo veig l'aigua
prou transparent
i els codons,
doncs, no punxen.
Com per fer això?
Si passés
amb les sabatilles,
doncs llavors caurien
moltes hores, potser tot el dia
mullat i...
Clar, no mola.
En qualsevol cas, si al primer tram veig
que descalç
no...
no és bona idea, sempre me les puc
posar pel segon.
Bueno, és qüestió
avançar-s'ho molt, això, eh?
Vinga, primer tram
és el més fàcil. A veure què tal
l'aigua estarà congelada, eh?
Vinga, vale, de moment bé.
Està congelada, però
puc passar, val, és segur.
Punxa un pèl...
Ai, ai, ai, si em cau és
un problema bastant gras, eh?
Ui, ui, ui. Ara uns pals de trekking
anirien...
Vale, vale.
Buah, molt fred, eh?
Vale.
Primer tram superat,
buah, pues no ha sigut fàcil, eh?
Oh, oh, oh, em fan mal els peus,
que flipes del fred. Oh!
Oh!
Oh! Buah, aquest és...
És que des d'aquí encara es veu
pitjor, eh? Es veu...
Buah, és molt caudalós, eh?
Què faig?
Buah, és que es veu molt caudalós, eh?
Potser...
Potser és que m'hauria de posar les...
les bambes, eh?
Buah.
Buah. Mira.
Mira, m'estic... m'estic...
Si... No, no, ja no
tinc prou... No tinc massa fred als preus, ja, eh?
Ha sigut instantani de sortir
i calmar-se.
Deixeu-me que m'ho pensi un moment.
A veure, en comptes de passar per aquí,
per allà ho veig una mica millor.
Encara que és més llarg,
per allà ho veig un pèl millor i veig les pedres.
Que aquí...
Aquí hi ha un tram que no les veig.
Vinga, sense pensar-s'ho.
No he... No he posat
les sabates, eh, al final?
Buah. Quant pot ser?
20 segons?
20 segons de patiment? Va, això no és res.
El problema sí seria si en caic, eh?
Vinga,
encara estic al tram
poc profund. Ai, ai, ai.
Vinga. Bé.
Bé, ara s'apropa...
S'apropa al tram profund.
Comença el dolor intens
als peus.
Oh. Vale.
No m'estic caient.
Vale. Estic al tram més profund
ara mateix. Aguanto bé.
Aguanto bé.
Vinga. Estira.
Força cada dalt, eh?
Però crec que puc. Estic sortint.
Estic sortint.
Oh, ho he aconseguit. Oh.
Ah. Ah, quin mal.
Ah.
Ah, quin mal als peus.
Ah. Ah.
Oh.
Ho he aconseguit.
Buah.
Pitjor del que em pensava, eh?
Ah. Ah.
Vale, vale. Estic recuperant.
Estic recuperant.
Estic recuperant la...
Ah, ah. Va baixant el dolor.
Oh, oh, oh.
No sé per què camino. Suposo que el moviment
em fa entrar en calor.
Vale, vale.
Bueno, pues, bona decisió, eh? Al final.
Anar sense les...
sense les sabates.
Amb les sabates
no m'hauria entrat tan fred, també et diré.
Vale.
Vaig anar allà, que hi ha un tros
més pla, sense pedres.
Pararé,
miraré els mitjons,
menjaré algo, descansaré,
i després continuem.
Les dotze.
M'he estat una bona estona, ja descansat,
sec,
mitjons canviats,
i bastanta mandra de caminar.
No anem molt bé, eh? Porto deu quilòmetres,
quedaria en trenta,
són les dotze, i...
Bueno.
Bueno. Veurem, veurem. Sempre puc acampar
en punt mig, eh?
Ara he de pujar aquí dalt,
que són dos-cents metres de desnivell positiu,
que dius, home, Enric, no és gaire.
Bueno, els dos-cents i pico que he fet ara,
de moment, bua, m'han costat, eh?
Estem a tres-mils
cincs, més de tres-mils cinc-cents,
tres-mils set-cents i pico
metres de desnivell positiu, jo crec que
per aquest motiu
deu costar més, no?
Pujar, o perquè estic cansat,
no sé, però...
Tu ets la sa erupta,
tu ets la nuq,
tu ets la poca pujada,
tu ets l'aigua
i jo...
i tu ets la cintura.
Bueno.
Toca creuar una pedrera.
Jo l'hi dic així, com a mínim,
quan hi ha aquests blocs gegants
que podria ser una tartera,
però els blocs són tan grans que jo l'hi dic pedrera.
No sé si es diu així.
Bueno, vaig a fer algunes fites.
Veiem aquí aquest...
Ostres!
Mira, ho veieu?
Una inscripció en àrab.
En àrab o en farsi, en iranià, no sé distingir-ho.
Uau!
Qui ha vingut aquí a escriure això?
I què deu posar?
Bueno, alguna cosa sobre Déu, segur.
Hòstia, però molt guapo, eh?
Espera, paro per fer-li una foto.
D'acord, pedrera,
n'he creuat bastantes a la meva vida.
Aquesta no és de les pitjors,
hi ha algunes del Pirineu que hauria d'anar saltant
literalment de bloc a bloc
amb blocs d'aquest tamany.
Aquest, com veieu,
sí que té una mica de caminat en terra.
I les fites aquestes.
Molt bé.
Doncs ara, d'aquí a poc,
arribem als
3.900 metres, tu!
Es diu ràpid, eh?
Avui als 4.000, però no arribarem, no.
Això millora a cada moment, tu.
Mireu aquests dos llacs amb aquesta aigua.
Però mira el color de l'aigua, eh?
Aquest color tan blau.
Jo no sé si mai havia vist un llac amb un color tan blau.
Sí, sí, el Laco di Sorapis.
Laco di Sorapis o Lago di Sorapis, bueno.
Això està a les dolomites italianes, sí.
Però allò és les Rambles.
Lago di Sorapis és les Rambles.
Aquí estic sol.
Sol.
Brutal.
Bueno, vaig a fer una cosa una mica arriscada.
Si segueixo pel camí,
arribo al llac, i per travessar
el llac a la pista,
pista...
Bé, bona, diu, segons
el mapa, que hi ha un altre pas
de riu.
Que no vull fer.
En canvi, segons el mapa, si vaig per aquí, que no hi ha camí,
m'ho podria estalviar.
En principi.
En principi, sí.
Vaig a intentar-ho.
Com veieu, són blocs molt grans,
però no és molt
de tros, llavors, bueno.
Crec que per allà
m'agrada més que per aquí.
Bueno, ja porto un trosset
de moment bé, però clar, l'avançament és lent.
No sé si me'n penediré.
Però és que un altre creuament
de riu no volia fer ni de conya.
Bueno, ja està la pista.
És l'objectiu.
Però, segur que
aquí a baix hi ha un drop
brutal. Ja ho veurem.
Complicat, eh?
Es pot, eh? Estic avançant, eh? Però...
Hi ha algunes cregudes
que he de ficar el cul a terra,
anar molt de compte, que la
pedra no es mogui. Molt fàcil
torçar-se el tornei.
I a sobre fa com una hora
que no tinc aigua. Tinc bastant
de set, però bueno, ara al riu espero que
pugui carregar. Mira, mira.
És que mira quin pas, eh?
Mira, mira.
Pas estret, eh?
D'acord! Aconseguit!
Ostres! Doncs sí
que s'ha de creuar l'aigua! No, home, no!
Allà!
Allà es pot passar sense
sense mullar-me.
Visca! Sí, sí, sí.
No sapia que m'hagués mullat a saco.
L'aigua aquí no és blava.
No sé per què té aquest color.
Però agafant-la d'aquell color
em faria cosa per beure, però
d'aquí, cap problema.
Molt bé, doncs trec el filtre i vaig a hidratar-me
una mica.
D'acord, doncs estic aquí al llac.
Veig uns campistes.
Però campistes de tenda, d'aquesta...
de càmping, eh?
Molt bé!
Molt maco, molt blau.
D'acord, com us he dit,
ara ja estic en pista.
Ara la venja és més ràpid,
però són les dues.
Són les dues
i queden 25 km.
Si anés a 5 km
per hora, cosa que
no passarà, però ara
anem a suposar, són 5 hores.
Per tant, acabaria a les 7.
A les 7 ja s'ha anat el sol, però trigaré més.
Per tant, és molt possible que
si vull arribar fins al poble aquest
hagi de caminar
fins a les 8, potser.
No ho sé.
L'altra opció, com us he dit abans, és acampar abans.
Ho decidiré sobre la marxa.
Fins ara!
Actualització a les 3 de la tarda.
20 km, queden 21.
No para de pujar, això, eh?
No para de pujar, però...
Buah!
El paisatge és increïble, eh?
És el paisatge, potser,
més estrany que he vist a la meva vida.
És que és molt estrany, eh?
No hi ha ni Déu.
No hi ha res.
Uns matoixos, l'única vida.
És que...
Sense paraules, tu.
Bueno, seguim.
Actualització a les 4 de la tarda.
Ara he parat 20 minuts.
Ho necessitava.
Estic molt fatigat, eh?
Serà...
Serà molt dura aquesta tarda.
Molt.
Actualització a les 5.
Segueixo caminant
per la immensitat del Pamir.
Porto 28 km.
Me'n queden 13, crec.
Es pot.
Vinga, es pot.
Actualització a les 6.
Queda mitja hora perquè se'n vagi el sol.
I queden 9 km
per arribar a Buluncul.
I he decidit que tiro.
Sí, tiro fins al poble. Era d'esperar.
Ja em coneixeu.
Tinc el frontal aquí, a la butxaca, per si l'he de treure.
Només queden
100 metres de desnivell positiu.
Per tant, en teoria el que queda
és fàcil.
M'interessa arribar
perquè demà he d'anar
fins a un altre poble que es diu
Alinquil
o algo així.
I bueno, en fi.
Ja us ho explicaré demà. Però que m'interessa arribar
a Buluncul. Allà
en teoria, agafaré una teoria i
en pràctica entraré a una
guesthouse homestay.
N'hi ha vàries.
I a veure si em donen de menjar.
O alguna cosa.
Com veieu, ja no em tocarà més
el sol durant el
que queda de dia. I
ara mateix els colors
són encara més impressionants.
Actualització a les 7 de la tarda.
Ja es veu Buluncul.
Ja veig des d'aquí les llums.
3,7 quilòmetres.
Ara estic a
Cosambès Pas, que és ja
l'última
pujada del dia. Ara ja tot baixada.
Fuat, el dia d'avui...
Increïble.
Després fem resum, però
ufff...
Buluncul, ens ha arribat.
Bé, no hi ha
absolutament cap il·luminació
excepte la de les
quatre cases que
hi ha. És això.
Ara mateix no sé ni com
és el poble. Bé,
la que és causa meva...
Bé, no he reservat ni res, eh? Vaig a demanar.
Crec que és aquesta d'aquí o una
per aquí.
Són les
9 i pico.
Parlaré fluixet perquè
mireu on estic.
Crec que en aquestes habitacions hi ha
altra gent dormint, però no ho tinc clar.
A veure, és que
resulta que arribo a la West House
i hi ha un grup de 8 alemanys
i 4 guies
tàgics, que estan fent una ruta
4x4, crec, o alguna cosa així.
Els guies tàgics em diuen
Senta't, senta't.
Vine amb nosaltres. I, bueno,
m'han estat preguntant un munt de coses sobre
el meu viatge. M'han donat
un parell de sopes que, bueno,
sí.
I crec que això costa 25 euros,
segons he vist a les reviews, però no
m'ho han dit. Llavors, clar,
suposo que les habitacions normals dels
convidats estan ocupades pels alemanys
i jo estic aquí, que bueno,
està bé, però
bueno, no faré soroll.
Tenen
Starlink. Tenen internet
Starlink amb bastanta velocitat.
Llavors he pogut pujar el vídeo, parlar
amb la meva família, tal.
Molt bé.
D'acord, avui
41 quilòmetres i
1100, alguna cosa així, de
desnivell positiu.
Bé, els números no sembla tant, però
ha sigut un dia duríssim, duríssim.
És que, clar, pel matí
pel matí el terreny ha sigut
complicat. El pas de riu
i jo pensava que aquella
seria la part maca del dia, no? La segona part del dia
en la pista aquella, pensava que, bueno,
però no, no, no.
O sigui,
o sigui, la segona part del dia
ha sigut brutal, les vistes.
O sigui, un paisatge,
ja ho he dit moltes vegades, eh,
però estic impressionat
dels dies més,
dels jocs més impressionants
de la meva vida.
De fet, ara estic una mica trist i tot,
de pensar de no poder tornar a veure
això, aquesta meravella.
Bueno, si veniu a Tajikistan heu de venir aquí.
100%, 100%
és brutal.
Especialment a l'hora
de la tarda, a l'hora de la tarda,
a les 5, a les 4.
Bueno,
també la sensació, no? Suposo que influeix
arribar en cotxe fins allà no és el mateix que
arribar caminant després
de fotre't una pallissa de 80 quilòmetres
en dos dies, no?
Però bueno, tu has sigut
un gran, gran, gran, gran dia.
Encara hauran de passar uns dies per saber
per
per reflexionar i pensar si ha sigut
el millor, el segon, el tercer, però bueno,
top 3 dies de la volta amb una peu segur.
Tinc les cames desfetes,
desfetes.
De diners m'he gastat això,
cafès, cap, té,
ara m'endona per sopar.
He parlat amb
una persona, un dels guies parlava anglès,
els altres no, i refresco
el cap, refresco el cap.
Bueno, tu estic content d'haver fet això
amb dos trams,
perquè així demà puc
fer allò de coseta abans
d'arribar al poble aquest.
Poc més a dir, perquè seria
repetir-me.
Etapa reina,
etapa reina en totes les lletres, eh?
La volta amb una peu.
Fins demà.